if I was Chancellor now there'd be very
very little I could do honestly honestly
because if I come out and try and tax
the richest I will get attacked but all
of the richest and most powerful people
in this country in the world will attack
me then the newspapers will attack me
everyone will attack me and it will
become extremely difficult and unless
the the general public your average
British man and woman on the street
understands we need to deal with
inequality to protect our living
standards to protect our homes to
protect our children it will be
impossible so the demand needs to be
bottom up listen the reason I I speak to
the public rather than these politicians
because this is not achievable without
the support of the public this is not
achievable without the support of the
public without the broad support of the
public but the power that I have the
power that we have is if those guys win
the public will be driven to poverty and
what I'm offering is a genuine escape
from poverty I listen I don't need to do
this Chris right it's February it's cold
outside I could be in the Philippines
all right I don't need to do this I
don't need this hustle I don't need to
be attacked by the financial times why
are you doing it I do this because I
come from a poor background and I see
people that look just like me just like
my friends just like my family just like
the people I grew up with and I know
what the future holds for them right
I've been at the top right I've seen
what's happening I've seen the tsunami
coming and it's my town down there it's
people like me that are going to get
washed out listen this gets worse this
gets worse and I don't know if I can
stop it but I have to at least give it a
goal what am I going to do I'm going to
have you I would like to have kids one
day and I'm going to tell them I I made
my money betting on the collapse of
society that's the truth right right and
they're going to turn around to me and
say did you try and do anything